صباح الانوار لكم جميعا المشاهدين صباح
العربيه سنه سعيده جميله ملؤها الحب
والفرح والصحه والسعاده ان تبقى نصيحه
زميلتي ندى حجازي عملت اليويورك شعري
بمناسبه العام الجديد الذي اتمنى ليس
المصري فقد قل ايضا التونسيه احيانا هي
قمنا نيويورك في العام الجديد في الحقيقه
سنه 2023 تقبل بكثير من الامنيات
التونسيين لنقل ان العنوان الابرز لسنه
وتضررت منها كثيرا تحررنا منها همم في هذه
السنه كان هذا العنوان الابرز ونقبل على
سنه جديده التونسيون من اكثر الشعوب التي
تحب الاحتفالات تحب الاحتفالات خاصه
بالمرتبات وبالحلويات همم تاثرا همم
المطبخ الفرنسي والع الفرنسيه نحن نعرف
علاقه الشعب التونسي بمطبخ الفرنسي
واقباله على هذه الحلويات والمرتبات
التونسيون يحتفلون سواء خارج المنازل او
داخلها هناك من يتوجه الى المطاعم الى
السهرات الى
الحفلات الفنيه والنزول وهناك من يحتفل في
البيت ويخير ايضا الاحتفال العائلي
التونسيون ينظرون دائما
وامل كبير الى سنوات الجديده يعقدون
الامنيات اخر كل سنه ويتبادلون التهاني في
اجواء حميميه واجواء رائعه جدا فالحقيقه
هي هذه السنوات مجرد ارقام لكن في التقليد
التونسي دائما يستبشرون خيرا بسنه جديده
او بتاريخ جديد ويتمنون لبعضهم ان تكون
السنه افضل من صديقاتها كما نتمنى ان يكون
ذلك على كل العالم وعلى كل الانسانيه يا
جماعه يعني احلام اول شغله بدي اقول لك
مش الف مبروك نعيما بيقول ههه نعيما على
همم
اصلا النظر لالك فرحه يعني انت هيك شكلك
وابتسامتك
وخصوصا كمان هلا على اليويوير في يعني ندى
بتقول لك انه حطت لست لاهداف للسنه
الجديده انت في اهداف براسك كمان هيك لسه
مثل ندى
ايه طبعا هناك احداث ننتظرها واحداث ربما
نتمناها ان تحدث وانا في الحقيقه اريد فقط
ان اقول ملاحظه ان هذه السنه
مجاملات اللطيفه والتحذير الجميله
والجميله جدا من زميلتان نادين سهام في
ستوديو صباح العربيه
دائما هذه الملاحظات التي اعيش الملاحظات
اللطيفه في الحقيقه حتى المتابعين صباح
العربيه في تونس وحبدونها ويحبدونها جدا
شكرا على كل هذه الموجات الايجابيه وكل
هذه اللمسه من الحب
ميناء السعاده التي تمنحوني اياها في كل
مره اكون فيها في اللايف معكم اوه طبعا يا
احلام نحن نقول التونسيين نحبكم برشا وكل
عام وانتم بخير شكرا جزيلا لك
واحنا بنحبك برشا برشا
[موسيقى]
هو عامل جدا كل واحد يطمح بشي حاسه
المروحه
اكثر في روحي ويعرف روحه اكثر تونس
[موسيقى]
كل عام وانتم بخير
برشا كرم
نتمنى لتونس فيغيمان اللي تكون بليد تتقدم
هي من هنا للقديم واحسن
مبروك 2023
[موسيقى]